et pour en parler nous sommes avec
francesco rizzuto professeur de droit
européen l'université de cette ville
bonsoir francesco musique merci d'être
avec nous en direct c'est franz le
président sortant en tête c'est pas
vraiment une surprise mais avec une
telle avance on pouvait s'y attendre à
ce que sa victoire était clair ce quiz
quelque chose car il ya six semaines ou
de mois on pensait qu'ils gagneraient
dès le premier tour
cela était peut-être trop optimistes
mais ça n'a pas été le cas dans le flou
alors on sait si l'on comptabilise tous
les matches et voit se rend compte qu'il
a obtenu 43 0 67%
mais si on ajoute les voix du maire de
varsovie et du présentateur de
télévision
ken 44 0 1% des voix chacun donc si on
prend le centre droite ils sont le
candidat acide et chaque année c'est de
là que soit son passé sont égaux et il
faut ensuite aller chercher d'autres
voies dont ce n'est pas assez un très
bon résultat lorsqu'on perd une élection
où lorsqu'on ne se débrouille pas si
bien qu'on espérait il est facile de
dire qu'on a gagné
alors c'est vrai qu'en pologne aussi il
y avait le contexte de la crise
sanitaire est ce que ça a joué ça a pesé
pour vous sur les résultats de cette
élection et un soutien du gouvernement
ni la magie des costumes polonais bebo
ne dit pas exact où jean exactement à
c'est la question que nous faisons
je pense plus l'aja au delà de la
situation sanitaire
cette élection porte sur l'avenir de la
pologne
sans vouloir être trop emphatique auto
dauphin et je pense que les gens seront
enfin que la pologne a quitté la route
elle s'éloigne de l'europe occidentale
nous avons vu une manifestation sur
manifestations beaucoup de personnes se
rendent compte que la question
électorale c'est la faune dames la
nature fondamentale de la pologne vous
dit 'le seynois s'éloigne de la route
occidentale qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire par là en quoi la pologne ses
droits tels de l'europe
oui google zürich 1 je vais vous donner
des exemples 5,5 plainte contre la
pologne soit par la pologne ou par la
commission de l'union européenne et la
pologne ne respecte plus ses engagements
selon l'article 2 du traité de l'union
européenne elle a une idée très étrange
de l'indépendance du système judiciaire
pologne a effectué une purge au sein du
judiciaire polonais cela fait 30 ans
amélie 1991 et la chute du communisme
on disait que le système judiciaire
était communiste mais ce n'est pas le
cas ils sont moches unité idéologique de
la justice très désuète qui remonte à ce
qu'on pourrait qualifier d'ancien régime
deuxième exemple ils utilisent les
médias notamment les médias publics afin
de créer un état illusoire pour les gens
il ya également un troisième exemple
utiliser les finances gouvernementales
afin de récompenser les personnes qui à
respecter leurs priorités et punir
d'autres personnes
la nomination des juges la perte
d'indépendance des juges les médias la
pologne lior complètement la cour
européenne de justice
ils ont toujours sur leur conception
comme faisant partie de l'europe de ce
qui remonte aux années 1930
et c'est un véritable problème mais dom
ils ont de la chance parce que l'union
européenne fait confiance à la cour de
justice et à la commission qu'elles
n'ont pas de conseils les gouvernements
ne souhaite pas utiliser l'article 7
il pourrait suspendre l'adhésion de la
pologne tout comme de l'hongrie de la
hongrie d'ailleurs merci
francesco risotto nous avoir apporté
votre analyse en direct sur rtl france